Mike pillow also known as Mike Lindell
the CEO and founder of MyPillow was in
Des Moines Iowa for Donald Trump's
canceled rally this was the rally that
due to depending on who or what you
believe either because of a tornado
watch or because of low attendance
depending on who you ask there's
conflicting views was canceled my pillow
Mike Lindell was there and he made an
incredible statement
he says he has blown I'm calling it
blown he says spent he has blown 40
million dollars on all of this election
nonsense now the last time I interviewed
pillow or prillo as some call him he he
told me he was at 35 million spent as of
that point in time we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
clearly the machine lawsuits have upped
that to 40 million here he is explaining
it what we're doing with
we're offering stock to the public I
want every person out there to have a
little piece of the pie our boys for
this country I write with the money that
I use to save this country that I've
been outspending I've spent over 40
million dollars unbelievable hang on a
second he's spent over 40 million
dollars on nothing on on literally
nothing
spent any uh and uh I need help you know
we need help but we need help making the
voice bigger yeah and we need help uh
the money that we've and you'll see this
when this happens I can't tell the
details the lawyer said I will only let
you tell this much you know yes they see
yeah okay so pillow I mean listen I it's
increasingly a sad story I believe
pillow is a True Believer he does seem
to believe this stuff and according to
various reports he's wrecked his family
life with this election nonsense and he
spent 40 million bucks I think he has
like two or three hundred million so
he's still going to be fine but that's a
lot of money to waste he then during the
same interview if you can call it that
says he put bed bath and be excuse me
bed bath it's so ridiculous I'm choking
on my own words he says that he's
responsible for Bed Bath and Beyond's
bankruptcy because they stopped carrying
his pillows or something you know they
were afraid in fear and and they uh I
said no the real people are gonna are
gonna not gonna shop there if you do
this to me yeah and that's what happened
that's exactly what happened but you
know I feel bad that all those jobs are
lost these ones that are going bankrupt
and stuff um we um
If Only They had my pillow pillows
available uh they would have been saved
that is uh that is a cautionary tale
okay and then lastly this is now totally
Beyond parody he pillow claims he has
new election crime evidence he's no
longer calling it election fraud he's
now calling it election crime and he
says that in two weeks it's going to be
released talk real quickly about what
you talked about the crime and when can
when can we expect that okay this is
real important that Allah you can go to
electioncrimebureau.com right the
electric crime Bureau I formed about uh
oh about a month and a half ago now and
uh within two weeks that's why I say
we're getting together now okay so in
two weeks they're gonna be publishing
that information you would think that by
now his family would have intervened
except it seems as though the
relationship with his family is wrecked
so they may have completely lost control
of pillow a sad and cautionary tale okay
the conspiracies can drive you closer to
bankruptcy it's not just benign when you
believe in this stuff you could get
grifted into donating to someone like
pillow or Trump or you could end up uh
you know skating off with the for 40 40
million dollars and uh of being in in
the situation pillow now finds himself I
don't expect any big election in crime
Bombshells in two weeks but I I've been
wrong before just not about this topic
and I could be wrong again